the Mighty Thor is virtually synonymous
with his thundering Warhammer but
unfortunately for him
mule near didn't make it through thor
ragnarok intact the good news in
Avengers infinity war Thor gets his
godly hands on an even more powerful
weapon storm breaker if you're curious
about its mythological roots and its
cosmic comic book origins here's the
truth behind Thor's new hammer the norse
arsenal norse mythology is full of
magical weaponry so it's probably not
surprising that Stormbreaker isn't the
only other tool wielded by the god of
thunder
in fact Thor rolled into battle strapped
with more magical weapons than anyone
including tier the God of War kneel near
is the most important but if you're only
familiar with it from the comics and
movies it might surprise you that the
whole thing about being worthy was never
actually part of the original myths
instead Thor was the only one who could
have to the hammer simply because it was
really really heavy to the point where
he even needed special equipment to lift
it the Megane gourd was a magic belt
that doubled thor's already considerable
strength and the yarn gray peer or iron
grippers were gauntlets that allowed him
to control neil near despite its heavy
weight and unbalanced handle it's worth
noting that the Megane yard actually
does exist in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe when happy hogan is clearing
out avengers tower and spiderman
homecoming he mentions it as one of the
items that's boxed up for transport beta
ray bill
unlike mule near Stormbreaker doesn't
have its origins in classic mythology
instead it's pure Marvel Comics where it
belongs to another character beta ray
bill when legendary creator Walt
Simonson arrived on the book in 1983 the
first thing he did was tell a story
about what would happen if someone else
was worthy enough to have two doors
hammer that someone was a super-powered
alien beta ray bill was chosen to defend
his people as they traveled through
space as refugees and fought Thor to a
stalemate due to a misunderstanding
during the fight his noble heart allowed
him to lift the hammer and take the
power himself once odin found out that
someone else had taken his sons power
his response was to demand that thor and
bill fight each other to the death in
the fiery realm of scart
not exactly the best example of
parenting especially since bill won that
one too instead of fighting to the death
though bill rescued Thor and brought him
back to Asgard a test of his worthiness
that was Odin's plan all along
to reward bill Odin convinced Eitri and
the dwarves of medieval ear to craft a
second hammer Stormbreaker it gave bill
all of Thor's powers and with that Thor
and Bill became both brothers and allies
while he hasn't really appeared in
person we do know that bill or at least
someone who looks an awful lot like him
does exist in the MCU in Thor Ragnarok
you can briefly spot a sculpture of
bill's head at the grandmasters
gladiatorial arena along with a villain
called the by beast no really the mace
the storm and the Frog Lee beyond
Stormbreaker there are a couple of other
Asgardian weapons of note in the Marvel
Universe the most prominent is probably
thunder strikes mace thunder strike and
yes the dude and the weapon both have
the same name it turns out Erik
Masterson is not an exceptionally
creative superhero he was bonded with
Thor for two years in the 90s and when
they were separated Odin gifted him a
magical mace he could use to continue
fighting evil it's functionally
identical to mule near but with one
major difference its inscription reads
the world still needs heroes drop that
one on your opponent's next time you get
in some Marvel Comics trivia
there's also storm caster a hammer that
Loki once gave to storm of the x-men and
yet another attempt to cause trouble for
Thor considering that storm can already
call down lightning to obliterate
whatever she chooses and that she's
already been worshipped as a goddess on
earth it seems a little excessive
that might be why she didn't keep it the
Marvel Universe's weirdest hammer
however comes from a story where Loki
turned Thor into a frog when he
recovered his hammer Thor struck it on
the ground and transformed into a six
foot six inch frog with a helmet and a
magic hammer because comics are great
several years later another frog who had
once been human was revealed to have
hefted a sliver of guru that broke off
of mule near in that story transforming
himself into the tiny frog of thunder
frog yarn Bjorn the iron bear Thor
wasn't always worthy enough to left me
all near and during his centuries as a
hot-headed arrogant brawler he had
another weapon of choice when it was
time to go bust up some frost giants an
axe named yarn yarn
norwegian for iron bear the name is
fitting it's a weapon that's almost as
tough as Mjolnir and it's a good thing
too when Thor doubted his own worthiness
and found himself unable to lift it mule
near found a new wielder in the form of
a mysterious female Thor the Odinson
took up yarn Bjorn once again because to
a man without a Hammer Every Problem
looks like you could probably solve it
with an axe ultimate Mjolnir in terms of
visuals the MCU version of Stormbreaker
doesn't quite resemble beta ray Bill's
hammer although it has the same basic
shape and they call it an axe but
whatever same difference anyway it bears
a striking resemblance to the version of
mule NIR carried by Thor of the ultimate
universe if you're not familiar with it
Ultimate Marvel was a publishing imprint
that kicked off in 2000 with a more
cinematic style but the characters
didn't take long to diverge pretty
wildly from their core universe
counterparts with Thor readers were
initially meant to be unsure of whether
he was a mythical God brought to earth
or a delusional but extremely handsome
mental patient either way his suit and
Hammer were technological not magical at
first eventually his godhood was
confirmed and it was revealed that the
techno mule near he carried was designed
to look like his memories of his actual
godly hammer the ultimate universe was
eventually destroyed but the hammer
found its way to the core marvel
universe where it wound up in the hands
of the extremely unlikely Volstagg the
voluminous who was transformed into war
Thor the cinematic Stormbreaker Thor's
quest for a new hammer is a major plot
point in infinity war and it lifts a lot
from the comics in this version medieval
ear is a forge in space orbiting a dying
star and the hammer forged by Eitri is
basically an upgraded version of mule
near in addition to the usual flying in
smashing it also gives Thor the ability
to control the Bifrost which was
previously a property of only Heimdall
sword there's one more really cool thing
about the MCU Stormbreaker though in a
representation of the disparate parts of
the MCU coming together for infinity war
the hammer is literally built from
pieces of The Avengers and the guardians
of the galaxy while the heads were
forged from you and me Duvall ear they
were joined by a handle that was made
from groots arm breaking everything
together thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]